الشمولية Menominee Michigan البوهيمي
ألكيل آخر و quintanilla عين
رئيس مجلس الإدارة الذي لديه kimeta judogi no
Chewbacca Queen ومشاهدة Idol يدفع
أيضًا مملكة عجين البطاطس الحازمة
والجيميني التي لم تكن نيتي
soy de novo لا يوجد تحسين
لمنزل ثقافي كثيرًا أنا  Eleazar Jurado
يمر kochu karu EO بحث Google عن
غرفة في فندق تحتها Amita
عندما تكون في الهيدروجين في مصنعك
Amita tango لديك بعد من ملاذ
متكامل ، رأى Breanna لسانًا يطالب do
de Rohan أن تحصل على Jeremy pooja
pooja Katawa shoujo senator internet  مفهوم
سوميدا كواترو كواترو فيسنتي الميكانيكي الجديد ،
سأعرض الاسم تشيكيتو ميكايلا
وين تشونغ يانغ كي أكوا ريو ما سوكاه
جاما تشي تشي تشي مينه سانتا كلارا
أحبك دانيال نيجوسيو دي لا مون مم
-هم ك تاتشو لحظة هنا كاملة حق
قية ناضجة إلى  الغلبة على تلك
الاختيارات ستضع في عطلة نهاية الأسبوع على السلامي
[موسيقى]
التوابل ليست مؤلمة على الإطلاق إنها جيدة
عندما تستخدمها بالكمية المناسبة
اسمي رجا مونتانا  أنا أعيش في
حيدر أباد ، الجزء الجنوبي من الهند
بهارات مهمة جدًا في ثقافتنا
و 100 في المائة من جميع أطباقنا تحتوي على
بهارات اليوم نقوم
بطهي حيدر أباد دوم برياني ، والتوابل من
حيدر أباد برياني هي من
الفلفل الأحمر الذي نستخدمه من جونتور  و
Taurus ، وهو مركز الفلفل الأحمر
للعالم ، تأتي كلمة برياني من كلمة فارسية
تسمى Berrien وتعني المقلية
قبل الطهي ، لذلك نصنع معجون
الفلفل الأحمر الفلفل الأخضر والزنجبيل
الطازج قبل
طهي البرياني ، إنه جدًا جدًا  من
المهم طهيها في طبقات لأن
كل طبقة لها طعمها الخاص ، حيث
تشم الكثير من التوابل المختلفة التي
لا يمكنك الالتزام بها ، وتتغير النكهة
إلى شخص لم يجرب أبدًا
حيدر أباد ، أكل دوم برياني الدجاج ، إنه في
الواقع صعب للغاية  للتوضيح ولكن
الأمر يتعلق أكثر بوجود مفرقعات نارية في
فمك ، فهو يغير مزاجك ، كما أنه
يرفع من مزاجك ، يجعل التوابل المزاجية
كل طعام أفضل ولكن الكمية المناسبة
من sp  هناك حاجة دائمًا إلى الجليد من باتنا لي
من بعض الأشخاص الذين تم تعليقهم على هاينان في
دقيقة واحدة ، ماتت هاتريك ، لذا يتعين عليهم
إيذاء مملكتنا.
لا تقتل وظيفتك عندما
جاء الفريق الأصفر ولحم الخنزير إلى النحاس
وقد كانا هجينين يدويين متضامنين يحدث
لي لذا لن يقبل أي شرطي ردني.
مثل سلحفاة بركة
راعي كرر لقد قمت ببناء منزل يمكن أن
يأتي من جورجيا من كمبيوتر مونتانا
نام العمومي الحقيقي نورث أكاديمي miniprep
في زجاجة حاوية فرم قطع لا
بوتانا حفرة فاليخو أنا كان عامل منجم
فام
ميا مسكون موندو قطعتني بيندان
بيكين فريق أنت  أريد أوه ، نعم ، هذا الذي
رأيناه حارًا على مقياس من واحد إلى
عشرة ، هل هذه قطعة حلوى
[موسيقى]